A bird-inspired drone developed by EPFL uses
artificial wings made of fiberglass covered
in nylon which allow for easier maneuverability
in high winds.
And SALTO the leaping robot from UC Berkeley
has the highest robotic vertical jump and
can even wall jump look at SALTO I love SALTO.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow!
Kissenger lets you send and receive kisses
through your phone.
The attachment features high precision force
sensors under a silicon lip to measure your
kiss and transmit it to the device on the
kiss receiver’s phone.
This actually isn’t a new idea in fact Mind
Blow #16 back in 2011 and on Vsauce1…and
Mind Blow #46 in 2012 covered prototypes for
robot kissing devices.
There’s even another device called Kissenger
by a company called Lovotics.
But it looks like this new kissenger from
mixed reality lab is the most practical yet
since it's significantly more compact and
interfaces directly with your phone.
BAE Systems envisions a future where lenses
are made with laser beams controlling hot
air bubbles.
The Laser Developed Atmospheric Lens system
creates lenses by layering hot air bubbles
on colder air using laser pulses which then
refract light.
This concept is similar to how how current,
solid lenses made of plastic or glass work
but making one out of air would allow it to
be much larger and maneuverable.
This technique could also be used to deflect
laser attacks by dispersing the beam.
So basically like laser beam shields in sci
fi movies.
But this is just a concept for now - no prototypes.
Yet.
WaveOptics is developing wearable augmented
reality technology to overlay computer graphics
on the real world.
Their headset, nicknamed “the ghost” is
designed for developers and not as a consumer
device, and they say their fully transparent
display creates sharp holograms with a wide
field of view.
Their proof of concept videos show how this
could be used in work and leisure scenarios
- basically getting one step closer to turning
the world into a videogame.
ICAROS is a fitness flying virtual reality
game controller machine.
The active VR experience connects wirelessly
to a headset and demands your full body to
control flying through the game.
Navigating inside the rings requires shifting
your weight and is more like a futuristic
exercise device than a gaming peripheral.
Alright that's the last VR story for this
episode...okay one more VR story.
AxonVR wants you to feel virtual reality.
The HaptX is a haptic textile that can provide
vibration, tactile and thermal feedback for
feeling virtual shape, texture, weight and
temperature.
They claim the range of touch varies from
the brush of a butterfly’s wing to the impact
of a punch and the goal is for their system
to be available in theme parks and arcades
and not likely in your house.
Unfortunately.
A soft robotic sleeve can restore normal blood
flow after heart failure.
Traditionally, a failing heart has its blood
removed and passed through tubes and pumps
which increase the risk of blood clotting
but this new device works without contacting
blood.
There’s still more work to be done before
this moves onto human trials but soft robot
heart pumping is awesome and I just wanted
to show you.
So yeah.
The sun and footsteps are all that’s needed
to power these new streetlights.
EnGoPlanet installed kinetic tiles in Las
Vegas to help power streetlights, wifi hotspots,
video surveillance and USB ports for mobile
device charging.
The panels generate between 4 to 8 watts from
pedestrian foot traffic and dependent upon
the success of this four light trial, the
plan is to roll out large-scale installations
on the Vegas strips and New York City parks.
EnChroma are glasses designed to alleviate
red-green color blindness.
The lenses feature a patent pending multinotch
filter which cut out sharp wavelength of light
to enhance specific colors and separate the
red and green cones.
This helps to counter the overlap between
red and green which affects those with that
form of color blindness.
They allow people, for instance to easily
identify the color difference between a green
traffic light from a blue sky background.
Finally, researchers at Intel Labs created
an algorithm for mobile robots to navigate
cluttered environments.
The quadcopter is able to reach its goal through
this maze and navigate two hundred interwoven
strings and twenty poles.
It's a fun drone obstacle course.
I’m gonna leave you with large-scale programmable
disassembly of tiny robots.
And as always - thanks for watching.
Sound waves are picked up by this wonderful
mechanical ear, the microphone, which is really
a glorified telephone transmitter.
The power from the microphone is amplified
about ten million times by these vacuum tubes,
making the voice current strong enough to
operate the machine that photographs the sound.
Do you follow me?
And then this amplified current, is carried
by wires along through the theater and down
to the screen on the stage to connect with
the loudspeakers.
This is a typical layout of the stage set
with two horns behind the screen.
The receivers connected to the horns convert
the electrical vibrations back into sound
waves exactly the way the telephone receiver
operates.
So that while the picture is being shown the
sound, which was recorded, is reproduced in
step with the picture.
The screen is full of small holes so that
the horns may be placed behind the screen
to let the sound through.
This gives the illusion that the sound is
coming from the image of the speaker.
Simple, isn't it?
Huh?